tesla has reported record production and
delivery of its electric cars for the
last quarter
profits also surged from 16 million
a year ago to over 430 million this time
round
however safety concerns and gaining
competition
i mean the company may not be in for a
smooth ride
from trailblazer to mass market producer
analysts are watching closely to see if
tesla will successfully make the leap
the numbers look good tesla has
surpassed expectations with 180 000
vehicles sold in the first quarter
despite recent setbacks it remains a
star on the stock market
at 700 billion dollars it's worth more
than all traditional car manufacturers
taken together
but the race is nowhere near finished
with a massive expansion strategy the
electric automaker is now trying to
increase its sales figures
a newly constructed plant in shanghai
has already paid for itself
every third tesla is now sold in china
and billions are being pumped into the
construction of two more plants
the gigafactories in germany and texas
are due to go online this year
even so established automakers are
starting to catch up
in europe volkswagen fought its way to
the top spot in electric vehicles sold
last year
followed by the renault nissan
mitsubishi group while tesla came in
third
at the same time established automakers
are introducing new models
while several startups have also joined
the fray
and accidents have selling pioneer
tesla's image
the circumstances surrounding a fatal
crash in texas have yet to be clarified
influential consumer advocacy magazine
consumer reports says the autopilot is
dangerously flawed
chinese authorities too accuse the
company of poor quality
and the protests of a customer who
accuses tesla's faulty breaks of causing
an accident
have gone globally viral on social media
let's get more from this uh on this from
our reporter chelsea delaney chelsea
could have been in the studio
so a record quarter for tesla for some
reason there's still some
disappointment around how come yes we
actually have seen the stock uh
selling off a bit and after this report
and i think this just illustrates how
difficult
of a position tesla is really in tesla
is so hyped right now their stock rose
700
last year they're worth more uh than the
big three german automakers volkswagen
daimler bmw combined so they have
really enormous expectations placed on
them so even when
they're reporting you know a 75 percent
increase in revenue
deliveries doubling they still often uh
that still often
isn't living up to to the markets
expectations i think in particular
with this report yesterday investors and
analysts are a little bit disappointed
that tesla wasn't more specific
about their expectations for the coming
year they've said they expect
deliveries to rise about 50 and and this
year in the years ahead
for any other automaker that would be
really a very good
uh good expectations that they're giving
the market but for tesla
because expectations are so high that
isn't really meeting
the meeting the markets uh demands right
now
but competition is growing and
gaining can tesla expect to be overtaken
anytime soon
i think this is another thing that
investors are increasingly becoming
worried about tesla really
has put electric vehicles on the map and
for a long time they were really the
only name and
the only name in the game so they had
this sort of
dominance in the market but now they're
not the only
electric vehicle maker anymore you have
here in europe
volkswagen daimler and the us gm
ford investing billions tens of billions
of dollars into
electric vehicles and we are starting to
see tesla lose its grip on the market so
here
in europe tesla's uh share of the
electric vehicle market actually fell to
13
last year from 31 a year earlier so
that's a really
enormous job and that's in part because
automakers like volkswagen
are really starting to step up their
game in the us they're still worth it
they're still they still account for
about 70
of the market but they are starting to
lose market share so it's they are
starting to face a lot of competition
tesla's future plans are contingent on
these two new plants they're building in
germany and the united states uh how are
they going
well in the us they tesla said yesterday
that they do expect this um
to this this factory and texas to open
up by the end of the year
here in germany there's still a lot of a
lot of uncertainty surrounding this
plant that they've been building in
gruen haida it still hasn't gotten final
approval from german
german officials in part because of
concerns about the environmental impact
so that is something that's still very
much up in question
chelsea delaney thanks for bringing us
up to date